i have to keep my children safe  this side of the planet  seems less intent on killing our  children  father once said to me  if you pretend to be something long  enough  eventually you'll no longer need to  pretend  i feel we're becoming too human  [Music]  to be the parents that our children  deserve  we have to think of the future now  [Music]  you need to form your own ideas when the  trust passes the baton you'll be the one  to take it  i'm gonna convert them all one at a time  if i have to  i miss being able to believe that  there's someone out there listening  someone with the power to make things  all better  when are we going to tell them what we  discovered  [Music]  i have to keep my children safe  i am the prophet nothing can stand  against me  [Music]  to be worthy of souls love children you  only need faith  and that is one thing that this robot  can never take away from us  love  you the death of us all  what fun we're going to have today  you